[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
Charlotte's Web which makes a CBD oil a
hemp extract that has become one of my
go-to tools now I have never really
talked about CBD oil and cannabis has
never really been the plant for me and
over talking about him but nonetheless
after several nights of inexplicable
insomnia this is about a year ago I just
could not get to sleep saved my life and
after other fixes failed so melatonin
California Poppy extract dah dah dah dah
dah an elite athlete introduced me to
this non psychoactive extract and bam
problem solved I had some of the best
sleep that I'd had in months now I don't
use sleep aids on a daily basis but this
has become part of my toolkit and I hope
to be exploring other applications soon
CBD oil products have exploded in
popularity in the health and wellness
and fitness worlds in Charlotte's Web is
one of the top players that offers broad
spectrum hemp extract with CBD in the
form of oils capsules and topical
products Charlotte's Web products will
not get you high so that maybe that is
good news maybe bad news to you but it
does have some powerful benefits and
applications and it works with your
body's existing endocannabinoid system
endo meaning from within like endo
versus exoskeleton for instance so
endocannabinoid system works with your
body some of the most common uses are
for relief from everyday stressors help
in supporting restful sleep which is
what I most often use it for to bring
about a sense of calm and focus a lot of
my friends use it for that CBD is also
known or becoming known for helping
athletes to recover from
exercise-induced inflammation
Charlotte's Web hemp extract has
naturally-occurring terpenes flavonoids
and other valuable hemp compounds that
work synergistically to heighten
positive effects sometimes referred to
as the entourage
which you guys can look up making it
more complete than single compound CBD
alternatives or at least that is what
I've been told I do not know much about
CVD alternatives nor single compound in
any case
check it out this stuff has really
worked for me to jump over to CW hemp
dot-com for it / Tim CW is in
Charlotte's Web CW hemp comm forward
slash Tim to take a quick quiz which
will determine the best product for your
particular Ames lifestyle etc and they
ship to all 50 states Charlotte's Web
are offering listeners of this podcast
10% off of their purchase well there are
some exclusions I personally use the
extra strength CBD oils or the extra
strength capsules and you can see what
might be a fit for you on that page and
there is a 30-day risk free guarantee so
why not try it out
so get 10% off of your purchase at CW
hemp com forward slash Tim and
disclaimer these statements have not
been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration this product is not
intended to diagnose treat cure or
prevent any disease enjoy this episode
is brought to you by peloton which I've
been using probably for about a year now
peloton is a cutting-edge indoor cycling
bike that brings live studio classes
right into your home you can also do
on-demand which is what I do we'll come
back to that so you don't have to worry
about fitting classes into a busy
schedule or making it to a studio or gym
with a hectic or unpredictable commute I
for instance have a peloton bike right
in my master bedroom at home and it's
one of the first things I do many
mornings I wake up I meditate for a bit
then I knock out a short 20 minute ride
in my undies hard to do that at the gym
take a shower and I'm in higher gear for
the rest of the day it's really
convenient and has become something that
I look forward to so you have a lot of
options for one if you like you can ride
live with thousands of other riders
across the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes 20 minutes whatever
music hip-hop rock and roll or say low
impact versus high intensity or interval
you can pick the class structure and
style that works for you and in my case
I quite like Matt Wilbur's and I tend to
do on-demand and listen to a lot of and
watch many of the same classes over and
over but I'm kind of promiscuous and
also enjoy classes from a lot of the
other instructors they have peloton an
amazing roster of incredible instructors
in New York City with a whole range of
styles and personalities so you can find
what you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyze you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right gamification yadda
yadda yadda I didn't think that it would
work for me or in any way incentivize me
but they really 100% hit the nail on the
head I was very very impressed with how
motivating it was and it worked
tremendously to keep me pushing which
quite honestly takes a fair amount I can
get quite lazy particularly with
anything that edges on endurance which
is kind of more than five reps of
anything for me so check it out discover
this cutting-edge indoor cycling bike
that brings the studio experience right
to your home peloton is offering
listeners of this podcast a limited time
offer go to one peloton calm that's
o-n-e peloton PE L OTO and calm and
enter the code Tim all caps at checkout
and get $100 off of accessories with
your policy one bike purchase so get a
great workout at home anytime you want
check it out go to one peloton calm and
use the code Tim to get started
hello Tim Ferriss fans my name is AJ
Jacobs and I'm a writer and friend of
Tim's and Tim has asked me to guest host
the podcast today he's away he's off the
grid so he has outsourced
his podcasting duties to me which of
course is a very Tim Ferriss thing to do
and I undeleted with the opportunity I
pledge to work my ass off to entertain
and enlighten you as your designated
podcaster Tim asked me to talk about the
topic how to be happier in these super
stressful times so I'm gonna talk about
ten strategies most of these strategies
but not all involve gratitude and that's
because I have a new book coming out
it's called thanks a thousand and and
Tim read it and he liked it
thank you Tim grateful of course and
wanted me to tell you some of what I
learned because it is a it was a life
altering project for me the premise of
the book is that I go around the world
and I try to thank every single person
who had even the smallest role in making
my morning cup of coffee and that turned
out to be a buttload of people over a
thousand people because I I went deep I
went you know six degrees of gratitude
so I thanked the farmer and of the
coffee beans and the barista of course
but I also thanked the designer of the
logo for the coffee the truck driver who
drove the coffee beans the the guy who
painted the yellow lines on the road so
that the truck wouldn't veer into
traffic I love doing this when I thank
the inventor of the cardboard sleeve
that goes around your coffee cup so you
don't burn your fingers and by the way
those sleeves have a name they are
called zarf s-- z AR f and zareff's have
been around since ancient China made of
gold and silver so very thankful I
learned that and was able to impart it
to you
but the idea was to show that every
little thing in our lives
involves thousands of people that we
take for granted and in the book I talk
about the most interesting sometimes
weirdest stories as I went along the
quest but the backbone of the book is
the strategies the tools I learned in
how to be grateful because it really is
it's a discipline it doesn't come
naturally to most of us especially me
and learning how to be grateful is it's
one of the most important things I've
learned in my life because as
psychologists will tell you gratitude is
a key to happiness if not the key to
happiness there I have a quote from a
Benedictine monk who says happiness
doesn't lead to gratitude gratitude
leads to happiness and I love that quote
it's by David a rental stock or stoled
not sure how you say his name I figure
he's a monk so maybe he'll forgive me
but brother star I think is on to
something
I often visualize my personality and all
of human nature as having two sides so
you've got the Larry David side and the
mr. Roger side and they are constantly
at war the cynical pessimist and then
the grateful optimist and I actually
think I was born with a very strong
Larry David side but the exercises and
this project was meant to GUP the Mister
Rogers side get him ripped so he can
take on Larry David because I you know I
love watching Larry David on TV I'd
probably rather watch him than Mister
Rogers but being inside his head being
in that frame of mind it's not a happy
place especially now now before I dive
into the strategies let me give you just
a little context as I said I'm a writer
you can hear Tim interview me in Episode
two one one and my strategy is a writer
it's self experimentation I'll dive into
a topic immerse myself
liked him from the the human guinea pig
a few years ago I wrote a book called
the year of living biblically and for
this one I wanted to learn about
religion so I decided to follow all the
rules of the Bible as literally as
possible and there are hundreds of them
so I followed the Ten Commandments but I
also followed the less famous rules the
Bible says you cannot shave the corners
of your beard I didn't know where the
corners were so I just let the whole
thing grow and by the end I had this
crazy topiary hanging from my chin and I
did spend a lot of time at airport
security I looked like Ted Kaczynski and
the Bible also says you know the stone
adulterers so I tried that I used
pebbles didn't want to spend my life in
jail and the book was about the dangers
of following the Bible too literally but
it was also an exploration of whether
there is some wisdom in this ancient
book that might be applicable to today
and I met Tim right before that book
came out and we met in a rather unusual
way it was um it was like 12 years ago
and I get an email and it says my name
is Tim Ferriss I'm I'm writing a book
it's my first book I'd love to ask you
how you write books what's your process
and I was like you know this guy has
some cojones but sure I'll talk to him
and we get on the phone and he asks me
about my process it was it every I
realize it's like the Tim Ferriss show
but no one was listening except except
for him and me and at the end of the
conversation Tim says you know I read an
article you wrote in Esquire I had
written an article called my outsourced
life and in the article I hired a team
of people from Bangalore India to do
everything for me so they answered my
phone they responded to emails for me
they argued with my wife for me it was
it was fantastic because I just got to
sit back and read books and watch movies
loved it so Tim says he read that
article and he wanted to reprint it in
his upcoming book and I was in saying to
myself well this guy's first
time writer he's gonna sell about 200
copies I'm not gonna be an asshat and
ask him for a lot of money so I'm like
sure go ahead
print the article no charge cut to a
year later I get a call hey it's Tim
Ferriss that guy you talked to just
wanted to let you know that my book is
coming out in a few days and it is
number one on Amazon and I was like what
how the hell did that happen I mean I've
never been number one on Amazon and the
book of course was the 4-hour workweek
and my article on outsourcing my life is
the basis for chapter 8 and of course it
shows that tim has a brilliant mind that
disrupted the book business but oddly
letting Tim print that article for free
it turned out to be one of the best
business decisions of my career not by
planning but I've had so many people who
know me from the 4-hour workweek so it's
it's helped my visibility and get my
message out so karma is real sometimes
in this case it was real sometimes you
try to do a decent thing in a place you
in the ass but but this time it worked
so thank you Tim and thank you for
outsourcing this to me okay on to the
tips some of these are in the book and
some are not somewhere exclusive to this
podcast and there is plenty other stuff
in the book just so you know but here we
go strategy number one declare war on
the negative bias the evil evil negative
bias psychologists will tell you humans
are born with a negative bias so if you
hear a hundred compliments and a single
insult what do you remember the insult
well if you're a normal human being now
if you believe in evolutionary
psychology there's a reason for this the
negative bias it had survival value in
Paleolithic times so your 1000th
great-grandparents they they need
be extra aware of dangers the Lions the
the poisonous mushroom so that's what we
are programmed to notice but we're not
most of us are not on the Savannah
anymore
so this negative bias is quite an
unpleasant way to go through life a
major cause of depression and anxiety so
how do we fight this negative bias and
the best weapon according to many
psychologists gratitude particularly the
type of gratitude where you focus on the
hundreds of things that go right every
day instead of the three or four that go
wrong and I've been trying to do this
for years because I know the advantages
of living a grateful life I mean there
is a ton of studies on how it'll help
you battle depression it will it'll make
you heal faster grateful people are more
likely to exercise and eat healthy so it
it really is remarkable and I've been
trying to be more grateful so a couple
of years ago I started this ritual in
our house before every meal I would say
a prayer of thanksgiving but prayer is
it's not quite the right word because
I'm pretty agnostic so instead of
thanking God I would start a meal by
thanking the people who helped make my
food a reality so I'd say I'd like to
thank the farmer who grew these tomatoes
and the the truck driver who drove these
tomatoes to the store and the cashier at
the grocery where I bought them and one
day at dinner my ten-year-old son said
you know danfa it's kind of lame lame
ritual because they can't hear you those
people are not in our apartment so if
you really care you should go and thank
him in person and I was like that it's
an interesting idea that is a book idea
so thank you for earning your supper son
so I did I went on a trip I focused on
my morning cup of coffee and I went
around thanking people all over the
world a thousand of them and I would
thank him by email
or phone calls or I would visit them in
person and you know the reactions were
mixed some people were like you know
what what the hell is going on here is
this is this a pyramid scheme what are
you selling but but the majority we're
surprisingly touched so for instance I
remember I called this woman who does
pest control for the warehouse where the
coffee beans are stored and I said yeah
you know I know this sounds strange but
I want to thank you for keeping the bugs
out of my coffee and she said well that
that is strange but it that kind of
makes my day I I don't get a lot of
appreciation and it was it was kind of
like making anti crank phone calls I
felt like I was doing penance for the
obnoxious crank phone calls I made in
high school to my headmaster and it
didn't just affect the thankies the it
affected me it gave me a little burst of
dopamine because it was such a clear
example of how I had negative bias I I
was taking for granted all these
thousands of people that were needed for
my cup of coffee and all of the things
that went right so that I could have
this brown delicious liquid in the
morning and you don't need to go around
the world thanking people to get the
same effect you just have to be aware of
the hundreds of things that go right so
it's the amount of radical shift in
perspective and you can do it you can
take two minutes a day and just focus on
all that goes right in those two minutes
like you press the elevator button and
the elevator comes you get in the
elevator
it doesn't plummet to the basement and
break your collarbone or or make a habit
of noticing when something goes right
this has been a big change I try to do
this so when you're on a line at the
drugstore that goes fast
make a note of that like I will say it
out loud to myself and like hey look at
this the line is going fast because I
know that if I don't then next time I
want a slow line I'll be like oh my god
this always happens to me
I'm always on the worst slowest line
it's not true it's just because the
annoying ones are the ones that stick so
you've got a fight that you got to make
the good ones stick as well so that is
tip number one focus on the hundreds of
things that go right guarantee it'll
make you happier
number two savoring the art of savoring
and I mean savoring in both the literal
sense like savoring a taste and savoring
an experience because psychologists talk
about how savoring and gratitude are
really linked and savoring is all about
taking a moment and stretching it out
holding on to the moment as long as
possible and and shifting our sense of
time so that life's little annoyances
dissolve away at least for a moment
because otherwise life goes by in a blur
like a undifferentiated gray goo so one
of the best savers I met was this guy
for my coffee book where his name is
Edie Kaufman and he works at Joe coffee
which is the coffee shop in New York
where I buy my coffee and Ed's job he
goes around the world South America
Africa and he tastes all these coffee
beans and figures out which one which
ones to buy and I think that and in
return he showed me how to taste coffee
like a pro and it is quite a bizarre
ritual you dip a spoon in and you take a
huge loud slurp like cartoonishly loud
I'm not gonna do it I won't expose you
to that but the idea is you want to
spray the coffee all over your mouth
because there are taste buds in the roof
of your mouth and the cheeks you gotta
get them all so ed would do this and his
face would light up and he would start
spouting these crazy adjectives like you
know I'm I'm picking up notes of maple
syrup and soil and Honey Crisp apples
and I would take a sip and I would say
yeah I'm picking up coffee it's tasting
to me a lot like coffee
but because of Ed I decided you know
what I'm gonna pay more attention I'm
gonna just let that coffee sit on my
tongue for five seconds I can spare five
seconds and really notice the texture
and the acidity and the sweetness and I
started doing it with other fruit
- and it's not just foods but it's
moments it's finding moments in the day
and remembering them and putting them in
your memory bank because I often think
the way to look at life is like I'm a
collector of great moments and I
actually started a file on my computer
which I'm dorkly excited about because
it is having a big impact on my life it
is called the file a I call it the one
thing so every night I add to it and
it's a list it's a list of one thing I
remember I want to remember from every
podcast every conversation every TV show
book I want to remember something that
was interesting or helpful and write
that down in the file because otherwise
I forget everything so I have dozens of
one things built up and hold on I can
open one up alright then I love this one
was a the one thing I learned from a
podcast about Michelangelo and it was
that he didn't really want to paint the
Sistine Chapel because he thought of
himself as a sculptor not a painter and
he sent these tortured letters to his
friends about how he's a failure he's a
terrible painter how could he have
gotten himself into this and I love that
because of course you know it's one of
the great masterpieces of Western
civilization and here he was having
extreme self-doubt so find that
motivating I can have self-doubt because
Michelangelo did but sometimes it works
out in the end sometimes you paint the
Sistine Chapel alright so that is a
strategy to is to savor things to pick
moments strategy three is to practice
six degrees of thankfulness and this has
been a big obsession of mine for the
last couple of years how everything is
connected the book I wrote before this
gratitude book was called it's all
relative and it was about these
scientists and researchers who are
building a family tree of the entire
world like all seven billion people on
the
same family tree so that we can see that
as the philosophers of Sister Sledge
pointed out we are family we are all
family we are all cousins and they're
not finished they they have over a
hundred million people connected but
even now you can go on there and figure
out your connection to almost anyone on
the planet using DNA and using these
massive trees on the internet and you
know I would search like Barack Obama
and it would come out he's my my fifth
grade aunt's husband's brother's wife's
second seventh grade nephew that is the
actual that is the actual connection so
we're very close practically brothers
but it's it's the same with every part
of our lives we are the connection and
that's what I tried to do with this book
on gratitude that it takes thousands of
people to create any object it doesn't
take a village to make a cup of coffee
it takes the world to make a cup of
coffee and to give you an example I flew
to the mountain town in Colombia to
thank the farmers who grew the beans for
my coffee this small town and we got
there it was owned by family and eight
brothers and one sister the Guarani
Zoe's and it's a beautiful farm they
have the biggest chickens I have ever
seen these chickens are the size of
adult pit bulls but they also have great
coffee and and they showed me how the
coffee beans are grown there inside
these red fruits called coffee cherries
they they look like great tomatoes and
you ripped that off and I and there's
the bean and so I thank them for growing
the beans and helping to kick start my
day and and they said that they couldn't
do their job without a hundred other
people from all over the world like the
machine they use to D pulp the fruit
that's made in Brazil and and they have
a pickup truck which is made from parts
all over the world in fact
I looked it up in the United States
exports steel to Colombia so I went to
Indiana to thank the steel workers there
and it just made me realize how
connected everything is just the web and
actually I remember tim ferriss of the
tim ferriss show once tweeted a quote
from john muir that said if you pull one
thread you realize how connected it is
to everything else I think it was John
Muir if not it was a cousin of his but
that was the general idea and what I
think is it's interesting you know it's
it's a cool idea but maybe you're asking
how does this affect my happiness my
state of mind I think it does have a
profound effect in several ways first
reminding yourself that you're part of
something bigger is actually so crucial
and there's the story I love that it
sounded apocryphal but I looked it up
and it's actually true and it's that
john f kennedy when he was president he
went on a tour of nasa and they ran into
a janitor who was sweeping up the
hallway and john f kennedy asked what do
you do here and and the janitor said mr.
president i am helping to put a man on
the moon and I love that because because
if you reframe your job as being
something that's part of a greater
mission it will give you meaning and
happiness and second I think realizing
we're all connected it reminds you that
you can ask for help and I went to
dinner just like two nights ago with
this guy he was an entrepreneur and he
had a company and a few years ago it
started to go south and it was
collapsing and he thought to himself
well I built this company myself I'm
gonna fix it myself but it just kept
collapsing and getting worse and worse
and worse and finally he had to shift
perspective he had to say you know what
I didn't build this alone I had lots of
help from colleagues friends Mentors
and so once he gave up that myth of the
solo success that he did it all
themselves then he was able to ask for
help and ask for money so to me it's an
important perspective that you don't do
it all yourself you you you build it but
you build it with help from other people
okay strategy number four don't forget
you're going to die that is I'm only
half kidding that this is a useful
strategy but I'll tell you how I came to
it is I one of the people I interviewed
in my book was will McCaskill who is he
was featured on the Tim Ferriss show
he's brilliant man a philosophy
professor at Oxford he started the
effective altruism movement and I asked
well like what are you grateful for and
will said sometimes I'm just grateful
that I have arms and I love is a strange
answer but I loved it because it's it's
true you can it's easy to be grateful
for you know you get a raise but it's
not as easy to be grateful for the
things you totally take for granted in
arms so I do take for granted and they
are very handy you know I typed my book
with my hands and if you take this
strategy to its logical end it's that
you've got to be grateful that you exist
at all and that you won't exist forever
unless the radical life extension people
are correct which they may be but
they're probably not going to get to me
they may be my fifth grade grandchildren
will live forever but I'm gonna die and
I think you can either find that
depressing or you can find it liberating
and realize we only have one we have a
little brief slash here and I'm gonna
try to make the best of it and there is
um I've always been fascinated by
memento mori the reminders of death and
these have a long history in Rome when
an emperor or our general would win a
war he would he would ride back and his
victory parade on the chariot and they
had a servant
I'm whispering in his ear remember
you're mortal remember you're mortal
just to keep him humble and and I love
that they have in many classical
paintings they have skulls as symbols to
remind you that you're mortal and carpe
diem life is fleeting and I I actually
decided to put a skull on my laptop
screen like my screensaver and it's not
a it's not a scary skull because I
didn't want to be depressed so it's like
a fun light colorful skull but it
reminds me that I am going to die and
and to have this epicurean look at life
and trying to enjoy it try to make my
like that or other people's lives better
because I'm not going to be around
forever alright number five strategy
five alright this is a quick one
using gratitude to fall asleep this is a
strategy I learned from a psychologist
who came to one of my talks and I don't
remember the name so thank you
psychologist whose name I forget sorry
about that but the idea was that instead
of counting sheep at night you should
count the things that you're grateful
for and the key is to do it
alphabetically give it a little
structure so you know you could start
with a and you think I'm thankful that
my kids made apple pancakes for me on
Saturday and B I'm ungrateful that the
the bathroom and my workplace is not
very busy whatever so you do that and I
have never made it to Z I always fall
asleep somewhere between like F and an
hour all right strategy number six is
the house shalt not have nostalgia or at
least delusional nostalgia and this is
because I do believe that glorifying the
past is a thief of joy and I really I've
come to realize that the good old days
we're not good at all the
were disease-ridden they were dangerous
sexist homophobic racist they were
smelly I mean just thinking about the
the way streets were with horses on and
all right for my first book I read the
Encyclopedia Britannica from A to Z they
don't even print it anymore but I tried
to learn everything in the world and
that was when I read about history
that's when it became so clear that I am
really happy I live in the 21st century
and not 1918 or 1818 and whenever I get
the press like if I get upset about the
hotel charges in to me you know five
dollars for Wi-Fi I get annoyed but I
have a three word mantra that I find
very helpful and that three word mantra
is surgery without anesthesia and I just
trying to imagine that because that's
the way all surgeries were until just a
few decades ago and I know this is a
little counterintuitive because if you
watch cable news or your Facebook feed
it does seem like we're on the verge of
the apocalypse and there is a lot of
negative news and granted I do think
that the last couple of years have been
a huge step backwards and we've got to
fight to get back on course but I like
to take the long view and and it gives
me some hope I I am in the Steven Pinker
camp the writer of enlightenment now
that if you look at the long view of
human history that we should be thrilled
to be alive now because it is much less
dangerous there's much less suffering
than there used to be and this even I
saw in my coffee you know because I am
thrilled to have a modern cup of coffee
because if I had a coffee a hundred
years ago I do not know what would have
been in it because I read the terrifying
history of coffee which had the list of
adulterants
that were the list of stuff that they
put in coffee that the merchants would
slip in there anything you can think of
I mean there was it was dirt baked horse
liver was one was a they cut it with
baked horse liver there was lead arsenic
I mean you were taking your life into
your hands when you ate in the past so I
am thankful for the FDA I actually one
of the people I think was Teddy
Roosevelt's descendants because Teddy
Roosevelt was the president went who
signed the safe food Act into law
so don't wallow in the past all right
strategy number seven try to discover
the hidden masterpieces all around you
one of my favorite conversations during
this gratitude project was when I called
to thank the inventor of the coffee cup
lid and his name is Doug Fleming
actually it's not all in since it's the
particular lid on my cup and until this
time I had given very little thought to
coffee cup lids but when I spoke to Doug
I was blown away by the amount of
passion and thought that went into this
coffee couplet because he said he thinks
it's very important like a bad lid can
ruin your coffee it'll block the aroma
and that's a huge part it can send the
coffee spouting which decreases your
pleasure
so Doug he revolutionized coffee lids
he's like he was written up in Wired
he's like the Elon Musk of lids
hopefully a little more emotionally
stable but he he designed a lid with an
upside-down hexagon so you can really
burrow your nose in there and there's an
extra-large hole to let out the aroma
and I loved that because it made me
really there are these little
masterpieces all around me that I take
for granted I'm I'm looking at the
on/off switch on my desk lint
which has the smooth indentation that
perfectly fits my thumb and it's lovely
if something is done well then the
process behind it is largely invisible
but if you pay attention if you notice
these things refuse to take them for
granted
it will tap into your sense of wonder
which is such an important part of
happiness all right strategy number 8 is
go analog so for this book to sort of
get the word out I decided I pledged to
write 1,000 handwritten personalized
thank-you notes to readers of my books
and articles and send them off and this
project has been simultaneously both a
huge pain in the ass and wonderfully
rewarding at the same time because what
I did was I put on my website you can go
on AJ Jacobs comm slash thanks and you
can fill out your name and address and
and the message and that's what I loved
is people have been filling out these
lovely messages about the times they
read my book and that they are wonderful
sometimes very weird I've gotten a lot
of requests I've gotten requests to
write thank you notes to people's dogs
one guy wanted me to thank his ex-wife
which I thought was like conscious
decoupling and it's beste I have to draw
a taco for one reader so it's a little
odd but it is also it is it is it makes
it so real to have a paper and it's good
for me as the thinker and hopefully good
for them as the thankee it has raised my
happiness level and I really you can
read these articles about these studies
that writing thank-you notes can have a
lasting impact on your happiness so this
one study had people write one page
thank-you notes
to someone who was important to them you
know a mentor or a relative and then
deliver
the thank-you note in person read it to
that person you are thanking which is it
can be totally awkward I did this I had
a boss at my first newspaper and I I
read to him how much he meant to me and
it was it was indeed awkward but but I
think it was good for both of us at
least for me and and there was recently
a study that said we overestimate the
the level of awkwardness when we thank
people and underestimate how much impact
it will have so I do recommend writing
the thank-you notes by the way two other
quick studies on gratitude that might be
useful one was a study I believe it was
Wharton study that said if you use the
phrase thank you it is not as effective
as using the phrase I am grateful so
because I guess thank you it's just
become so robotic so if you can mix it
up and trying to get out of the just the
wrote thank you and try another phrase
that apparently has more impact I tried
this with my wife I said to you know I'm
I'm deeply grateful that you took our
kids to the orthodontist and she looked
at me she's like oh are you in a cult
like what's going on here so that don't
don't use deeply in my experience but
mixing up the phrases is a good idea and
the second study I found interesting was
that people who had job interviews and
then wrote a thank-you note have any
more we're more likely to get called
back so maybe obvious but they really do
work alright strategy number nine is to
fake it till you feel it fake gratitude
till you feel it and this has been a
theme in many of my projects along with
Tim's projects I think that when you act
in a certain way it it affects your
thinking that the outer effects the
inner the behavior affects your mind
there's a great quote I wish I had come
up with it it's actually by the founder
of Habitat for Humanity he says it's
easier to act your way into a new way of
thinking than to think your way into a
new way of
acting so I would say I experienced this
quite a bit during the gratitude project
I would I would wake up with my Larry
David side strong the grumpy side strong
but I would force myself to call or
write notes thanking people and just by
doing that and realizing what people had
done for me what what all that had gone
into my coffee I was my mind caught up
you know I tricked my mind by by doing
the action so act as if you're grateful
and eventually your mind will catch up
hopefully and finally use gratitude as a
spark to action and this is important
because I don't want to I think there's
a fear among some people that gratitude
has a downside that it might lead to
complacency that if we're too grateful
we'll think Oh the world is perfect and
we don't need to improve that you need
to be angry to change things to affect
social change and it turns out the
opposite is true there are studies that
show that the more grateful you are the
more likely you are to help others the
more pro-social you are and I have found
this on a personal level you know when
I'm in a bad mood I am NOT interested in
helping others I just want to get out of
that bad mood
gratitude makes you want to pay it
forward and I saw this because you you
know you go on any supply chain and you
will see things can get ugly you know
there is the downside I'm capitalist but
there is a downside to global capitalism
there is a lot of suffering and
exploitation I read one interesting
study that said if everyone on this
chain were paid the minimum wage in the
United States then your coffee would
cost $25 I always thought $3 was
ridiculous but that was a sort of a
wake-up call but it makes you realize
that what we have what what I take for
granted is not available
millions billions of people in the world
and an example of this was water
you know I coffee is ninety eight point
eight percent water so I figured I had
to thank the people who provide the
water to New York so I I went upstate
and there are thousands of people
working at the New York reservoir just
so I can turn on this tap and get safe
water and their jobs are not always fun
the you know there is a job someone has
to pick up the the cow poop and the deer
poop around the reservoir before a rain
storm so it doesn't flow in to the
reservoir so it reminded me that there
are these people who spend hours on this
and there people around the world who
who have to walk part of the day much of
the day to get clean water and I was
actually I was talking to my kids
because I thought we could reframe the
glass half-full glass half-empty you
know it's I think we need to go a step
back you know it's not just that the
glass is half-full it's like the fact
that we have any water in the glass at
all though you can put it under a metal
tube and turn a switch and you have
clean water that's crazy so it doesn't
matter how much is in the glass the fact
that there is water is astounding so the
paradox the wonderful paradox is the
more you focus on other people the
happier you are I mean I spent most of
my life my 20s and 30s focused
exclusively on my own happiness and and
when you are chasing your own happiness
as the sages will tell you you you're
not always going to be happy and not get
it it's too much pressure on yourself so
paradoxically but wonderfully focusing
on someone else's happiness will
actually make you happier alright so oh
and by the way a little plug for water I
am becoming aware of this
I asked will McCaskill the philosopher
what is the best or a good water charity
and he suggested dispensers for safe
water which gives peep
the ability to clean their water in a
cheap way
so a little plug for them alright so now
my conclusion is uh I'm just very
grateful that this I was able to take
this undertake this project gratitude
and I've become you know sort of an
evangelist I I want my friends to follow
the gratitude trail so it doesn't have
to be coffee it could be a lightbulb or
a pair of socks and and you don't have
to travel the world you can just do a
small gesture like sending a note to the
designer of a logo you love or looking
at cashier in the I mostly I just think
it's a mindset refusing to take things
for granted being aware of the thousands
of people involved that someone in a
factory made the fabric for the chair
you're sitting in right now or they or
the pants you're wearing someone went
into a tunnel and mines the copper for
this microphone so I could say my my
final - thank yous which is first - uh
thank you for listening and second -
thanks to Tim Ferriss for outsourcing
this episode to me I hope you liked it
and you can learn more in the book
things mm thank you
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday event provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
red and that I've shared with my close
friends for instance and it's very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek comm all is
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by peloton
which I've been using probably for about
a year now peloton is a cutting-edge
indoor cycling bike that brings live
studio classes right into your home you
can also do on-demand which is what I do
we'll come back to that so you don't
have to worry about fitting classes into
a busy schedule or making it to a studio
or gym with a hectic or unpredictable
commute I for instance have a peloton
bike right in my master bedroom at home
and it's one of the first things I do
many mornings I wake up I meditate for a
bit then I knock out a short 20 minute
ride in my undies part through that at
the gym take a shower and I'm in higher
gear for the rest of the day it's really
convenient and has become something that
I look forward to so you have a lot of
options for one if you like you can ride
live with thousands of other riders
across the country on an interactive
leaderboard keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes 20 minutes whatever
music hip hop rock and roll or say
low-impact versus high intensity or
interval you can pick the class
structure and style that works for you
and in my case I quite like mat will
produce and I tend to do on-demand and
listen to a lot of and watch many of the
same classes over and over but I'm kind
of promiscuous and also enjoy classes
from a lot of the other instructors they
have peloton an amazing roster of
incredible instructors in New York City
with a whole range of styles and
personalities so you can find what
you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyze you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right gamification yadda
yadda yadda I didn't think that it would
work for me or in any way incentive
ëismí but they really 100% hit the nail
on the head I was very very impressed
with how motivating it was and it worked
tremendously to keep me pushing which
quite honestly takes a fair amount I can
get quite lazy particularly with
anything that edges on endurance which
is kind of more than five reps of
anything for me so check it out
discover this cutting-edge indoor
cycling bike that brings a studio
experience right to your home peloton is
offering listeners of this podcast a
limited time offer go to one peloton
comm that's Bo and e peloton PE l OT o
and.com and enter the code Tim all caps
at checkout and get $100 off of
accessories with your polish on bike
purchase so get a great workout at home
anytime you want check it out go to one
peloton calm and use the code Tim to get
started this episode is brought to you
by Charlotte's Web which makes a CBD oil
a hemp extract that has become one of my
go-to tools now I have never really
talked about CBD oil and cannabis has
never really been the plant for me and
we're talking about hip but nonetheless
after several nights of inexplicable
insomnia this is about a year ago I just
could not get to sleep save my life and
after other fixes failed so melatonin
and California Poppy extract
da-da-da-da-da an elite athlete
introduced me to this non psychoactive
extract and bam problem solved I had
some of the best sleep that I'd had in
months now I don't use sleep aids on a
daily basis but this has become part of
my toolkit and I hope to be exploring
other applications soon CBD oil products
have exploded in popularity in the
health and wellness and fitness world
and Charlotte's Web is one of the top
players that offers a broad spectrum
hemp extract with CBD in the form of
oils capsules and topical products
Charlotte's Web products will not get
you high so that may be that is good
news may be bad news to you but it does
have some powerful benefits and the
applications and it works with your
body's existing endocannabinoid system
endo meaning from within like
No versus exoskeleton for instance
endocannabinoid system works with your
body some of the most common uses are
for relief from everyday stressors help
in supporting restful sleep which is
what I most often use it for to bring
about a sense of calm and focus a lot of
my friends use it for that
CBD is also known that are becoming
known for helping athletes to recover
from exercise-induced information
Charlotte's Web Hemme extract has
naturally occurring terpenes flavonoids
and other valuable hemp compounds that
work synergistically to heighten
positive effects sometimes refer to as
the entourage effect which you guys can
look up making it more complete than a
single compound CBD alternatives or at
least that is what I've been told I do
not know much about CBD alternatives
norsu will compound in any case check it
out this stuff is really worked for me
to jump over to CW hemp dot-com for /
Tim CW is in charge of CW canva.com /
Tim to take a quick quiz which will
determine the best product for your
particular Ames lifestyle etc and they
ship to all 50 states Charlotte's Web
are offering listeners of this podcast
10% off of their purchase while there
are some exclusions I personally use the
extra strength CBD oils for the extra
strength capsules and you can see what
might be a fit for you on that page and
there is a 30-day risk free guarantee so
why not try it out to get 10% off of
your purchase at CW Hema comm forward
slash Tim and disclaimer these
statements have not been evaluated by
the Food and Drug Administration this
product is not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease enjoy
you
you